vamos a resolver otros dos problemas de
demostraciones con paralelo gramos este
dice lo siguiente tenemos que abc de es
paralelogramo y queremos demostrar que
las diagonales se edifican entre sí o
sea que se cortan a la mitad vale bueno
déjame ponerle un nombre al punto de
intersección de las diagonales
voy a ponerle que es el punto entonces
lo que nos gustaría demostrar es que b
es igual a la de ikea es igual a ese y
para eso vamos a aprovechar los
triángulos que hay aquí y vamos a
intentar encontrar triángulos
congruentes vale bueno para hacer eso
vamos a vamos a observar primero este
ángulo b a b b tenemos que ver es una
línea transversal a la pareja de líneas
paralelas a b c d entonces este ángulo
de acá y este ángulo de acá son ángulos
internos alternos y por lo tanto miden
lo mismo lo voy a poner de este lado el
ángulo a b
y es igual al ángulo ángulo cd
d
de manera similar este ángulo es igual
este ángulo porque ahora esta diagonal
es una transversal a la pareja de rectas
paralelas a b y c de ba entonces déjame
déjame ponerlo con color digamos naranja
o con color rojo y con color rojo
entonces el ángulo b es congruente al
ángulo de s b
ángulo b
es igual al ángulo al ángulo de es de s
d
muy bien y además además de estos dos
hechos en el vídeo pasado demostramos
que si algo es un paralelogramo entonces
los lados opuestos miden lo mismo y por
lo tanto podemos decir que ave es igual
a cde entonces lo voy a escribir aquí
abajo en color verde o sea además
tenemos que ave ave mide lo mismo que
de que se dé muy bien entonces juntando
estos tres hechos podemos mostrar que a
hebe el triángulo
y el triángulo c y d son congruentes
déjame ponerlo por aquí vamos a poner
que estos tres hechos por criterio ala
nos permiten concluir lo voy a poner así
por criterio
por criterio ala
de congruencia de congruencia nos
permiten concluir que el ave que el
triángulo o ave ave es congruente
congruente al triángulo se ve al
triángulo
de verdad tenemos este ángulo es igual
este ángulo este lado es igual a este
lado y este ángulo es igual este ángulo
entonces tenemos justo el criterio
ángulo lado
muy bien y a partir de que los
triángulos son congruentes ya tenemos un
montón de información porque todas las
demás parejas de elementos
correspondientes también deben ser
iguales en particular tenemos que v v es
igual a ed lo voy a poner por acá
tenemos v es igual a ed entre y también
tenemos que ea es igual a s
es igual a que si no voy a marcar así y
así y si queremos podemos ponerle por
aquí que es por la dos lados
correspondientes correspondientes de
triángulos congruentes de triángulos
congruentes muy bien entonces con eso
demostramos lo que queremos porque justo
esto nos dice que es el punto medio dvd
y que también es el punto medio de hace
muy bien ya lo hicimos hacia un lado un
paralelogramo que cumple que sus
diagonales se cortan a la mitad vamos a
ver que el regreso también es cierto que
si tenemos un cuadrilátero en el cual
ambas diagonales se cortan a la mitad
entonces ese cuadrilátero es un
paralelogramo y para eso voy a pasar al
dibujo de aquí abajo es justo lo que
dije ahora tenemos que las diagonales se
cortan a la mitad déjame llamar otra vez
a este de acá el punto entonces las
diagonales se cortan a la mitad y
tenemos que demostrar que a bs d es un
paralelogramo ok ahora lo que vamos a
aprovechar es este ángulo de acá
estos dos el a b a b y el c
cb y estos dos ángulos de acá son
iguales son iguales porque ambos son
opuestos por el vértice entonces déjalo
escribo por acá tenemos que el ángulo ve
a ángulo b
es igual al ángulo ángulo de s al ángulo
de s y esto le voy a poner que que es
por opuestos al vértice vértice
cuáles son ángulos opuestos al vértice y
por lo tanto son iguales pero observa
esto inmediatamente nos da un criterio
de congruencia para los triángulos a b y
c de por qué porque tenemos lado o sea
comparten el lado
con ese el ángulo
y el lado b con ed entonces lo voy a
escribir por acá que podemos concluir
que el austrian que el triángulo
v b es congruente al triángulo c y d
el triángulo c y b por el criterio por
criterio
interior el l de congruencia de
congruencia y como son triángulos
congruentes entonces cualquier elemento
correspondiente es igual al del otro
triángulo entonces en particular tenemos
que ave es igual a c d lo voy a poner
por aquí déjame ponerlo con color
amarillo
entonces ave ave es igual a c d
bueno ahí vamos verdad ya tenemos que
éste es igual a este de acá ahora lo que
vamos a mostrar es que bc es igual a la
de entonces ahora vamos a hacer lo mismo
pero ahora con los triángulos b c y d
como le vamos a hacer una vez más
tenemos que aquí tenemos un ángulo
opuesto por el vértice con este de acá
vale entonces tenemos que el ángulo de
ese ángulo p s es igual al ángulo de e
de e
le voy a poner
opuestos al vértice al vértice vértice
y entonces de manera similar concluimos
que los triángulos de ese triángulo b y
c y el triángulo de a son congruentes
triángulo de e
son congruentes de nuevo por criterio
criterio l
el de congruencia de congruencia sí
misma idea que antes coinciden en que es
igual a efe en el ángulo en e y además
de es igual a b y entonces por criterio
l a l son congruentes a partir de aquí
concluimos la otra igualdad que nos
interesa que es igual a veces que a de
ave es igual abc y como ya vimos en el
vídeo anterior si tenemos que las
parejas de lados opuestos son iguales o
sea ésta es igual a ésta y ésta
es igual a ésta entonces tenemos que el
cuadrilátero es un paralelogramo bueno
había otras formas de concluir también a
partir de estas dos congruencia de la
congruencia y déjame marcarlas con color
blanco esta de acá y estar acá está de
acá podemos concluir que el ángulo de ce
es igual al de einstein es igual a este
que el ángulo bueno y que el ángulo
bc que este de acá es igual al ángulo de
la idea entonces otra forma de concluir
es decir es decir lo siguiente es decir
que sabe es paralela hace de ave es
paralela a cede porque por ángulos
alternos internos por ángulos alternos
internos
y también tenemos que veces es paralela
a de a por la misma razón
vc es paralela a d
por esta misma razón entonces le voy a
poner así va bueno
de cualquier forma concluimos finalmente
a partir de que las diagonales se cortan
en la mitad que el cuadrilátero abc de
es un paralelogramo